we get on trt how's your dick function  you have morning wood still yeah yeah  okay libido solid how can you tell if  you're libido's solid you like you still  want to have sex you want a pork oh yeah  yeah yeah I got my testosterone levels  checked they're fine what are they  though what would you guess just buy it  I don't know just by like how cool I am  you could have super high tests but if  you don't lift or you know eat properly  you could still look like nothing well I  mean like clearly you know I'm like an  alpha yeah yeah  [Music]  my fasting glucose is 90. okay my liver  health is 30. that is not an accurate  statement what you just said Why That's  not a marker you're just saying my liver  health is 30. alt okay you want me to  like scroll through it or do you know  it's on this app so it's like oh it's  not actual like it's all displayed all  pretty he will fall for any scam this is  just some guy putting numbers into  charts